- [Gary] There's a flip.
2017 Flip Challenge.
There is a real arb here.
I can smell the arbitrage.
(upbeat music)
- Our big boss.
Our big boss, Gary.
(woman cheers)
Gary, Gary!
Gary's the guy.
- Thank you, my friend.
Think it's in the roof?
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Gary] The roof?
- [Man] The roof.
- [Gary] But you can't
just replace the roof.
- [Man] The roof is weak.
- The whole building?
- Yeah, we initially got because
we wanted to change the roof.
but when the engineers came--
- But then they realized.
They said forget it.
Okay.
("A Girl To Love"
by Koko)
Let's go, DRock.
- [India] DRock!
- [Gary] DRock, film me.
I'm confused.
- Let's go, come on over here.
- I'm confused.
(group laughter)
- Thank you.
- [Gary] Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Thank you for your hospitality.
Thank you so much.
- We are also grateful to you.
Yeah, so grateful.
- [Gary] Pleasure.
Thank you for having me.
Thank you.
- [Man 2] Gary.
- [Gary] Thank you.
Thank you, bye-bye.
("A Girl To Love" by Koko)
No, this is unpopular topics.
Say something out loud that you
think you actually believe
but a lot of other
people don't agree.
Husain's laughing
'cause he feels like that's his,
(group laughter), yeah.
You love being a contrarian.
This is a great
game for contrarians.
By the way, I actually
know that about you.
And actually, I know that about
you because the number one thing
that I look for with employees
is the ones who push against me
because they think, like
India for example, right?
You know push for
the sake of pushing and
actually don't believe it.
I do believe what you just said.
I think the current state of
parenting is fundamentally
broken and will be looked upon
as a bad place because I don't
believe in two
cooks in the kitchen.
The blending on it
is hurting parenting.
That divide and conquer of the
'50s and '60s actually is more
ROI positive.
Kind of like higher thought
of two cooks in the kitchen.
That there's a struggle, people
agreeing on these things is a
very difficult thing.
I think we all and I think it
creates an un-united front.
I think so.
Guys, you have to put
teeth around it otherwise,
it's not gonna work.
No, really.
It's got to be
things like parenting,
it's got to be the taboo shit.
- Well here's a
related on to yours.
I think that there
should be flights offered
with no children on them.
- Oh, that's interesting.
That's just a good idea.
(group laughter)
- [Man 2] A whole airline.
- Do you believe that or
is that just a random idea?
- No I don't
like flying with kids.
- Yeah, I've always
known you were a bad person.
(crosstalk)
Guys, with the technology
around headphones and
things of that nature,
it's become a non-factor.
- No.
- [Man 3] No way.
("A Girl To Love" by Koko)